what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch gravity falls episode 13 today we
normally put these up on mondays but
pushing this one to sunday a day earlier
because uh there's the batman review
embargo we want to dedicate time to that
on monday anywho if you're here now
leave a like if you can also uh
subscribe click the notification bell
get notified when our reaction from the
next gravity falls is up full length
watch along as we sync up with the time
code over at our patreon page along with
a bunch of other shows thanks to all who
have joined lastly then boys at prepper
thanks for helping us edit down these
highlights let's do this
[Music]
congratulations you're taking a cat
oh lucky we got tourists at nine o'clock
a whole busload of them
hot tamales it's a jackpot zeus make
some new attractions just just make them
wendy mark up those prices the higher
the better
higher
fleet them dry
oh boy it's like when you look at
tourists all you see are wallets with
legs that's not true
thanks for taking me to the mystery
shack daddy
now don't spend yourself all in one
place i'm feeling carsick
yeah
clean up
human wallets man if only that's the
true dream of capitalism you'll see many
wondrous roadside attractions be amazed
at the only known photo of a horse
riding another horse
oh it's unnatural so wrong preteen wolf
boy oh oh look at him all that hair this
is demeaning what i don't know demeaning
of that word
if you throw money out of me dances
make your son a stripper or
nephew chef whooper stickers you can
stick them on your bumper or
over your husband's mouth am i right
ladies how much hey it's on the house
that's the mabel difference oh you don't
make money by giving stuff away
no butts except yours out the door now
shut your yap and get to work uh
whatever happened to please and thank
you hmm
oh wait here they are
please never made me any money kid
grunkle stan why do i have to wear this
wolf costume i think i'm getting
hookworm gluing dog hair to your body
will do that oh god oh no what if you
hunted down a real attraction instead of
lying to people for a living and you
should be nicer to your employees too
yeah
unionize why do we even put up with it i
tried to give him a suggestion to
improve the shack once i had this idea
or i could be like the mystery shack
mascot question neither question mark
that sounds amazing oh cool yeah totally
stan said i couldn't handle it he said
what
we put the fun in no refund
i bet you'd make way more money being
nice than being a big grumpy grump to
everyone all the time ha you think you
know more about business than i do you
think you could wear this hat
i'd make more money on vacation than you
would running this place then why don't
you go on vacation
72 hours
you run the shack and i'll go on
vacation if you lose um yeah you got to
wear this loser shirt all summer oh fine
but if i win i get to be the bus for the
rest of the summer plus you have to sing
an apologizing song with lyrics by me
mabel
being a better boss than stan will be a
cinch prophet here we come
oh yeah
no can i help you sir i'm here to take
all the cash from your way christ
you wanted to see us mr barnes
hodo
oh yeah
are those shoulder pads uh-huh
it's just one of the many up-to-date
managerial tricks i learned from this
book i found popping up the kitchen tape
that's gonna say right out of the 80s
hugs say number two because the real
number one is you
know
[Laughter]
my job is to help you be your best
selves
satisfied everyday loving life very much
every day
perf
how can i make your workspace more wendy
friendly stan never lets me hang out
with friends at work doors open
sweet oh no
i believe this is yours questioning the
question mark as for you dipper
costume hey
head into those woods and don't come
back until you found an amazing
attraction that could be bad in the next
48 hours we're gonna fill up this jar
with 600 billion dollars yeah
wait do you know how money works of
course oh no
a latte
[Laughter]
time to use my old man powers
ah i'm having a heart attack no that
would give me a part i'm old that man is
a self-centered attention hog with no
regard for human decency
get him on tv
to get him his own show
wow
thank you see you soon tell mabel sent
you this is gonna blow those tourists
away
oh no i'm starting to have second
thoughts about this mabel uh i keep
forgetting my lines and this costume is
more uh
oh
[Laughter]
no
please have a refund
you've got a lot of cleaning up to do
please whoa all this rule stuff's
starting to make you sound like stan
don't be a mother effort wendy take the
rest of the day off with full pay of
course
mabel pines you are the best boss ever
it's going great i'm questioning the
question mark
oh
no no the game hasn't started is it shut
your yaps
[Laughter]
cash hour cash hour cash shower
dang
no you don't need to take your clothes
off
nope nope nope commit commit it nearly
killed me getting him into that cage
behold part gremlin part goblin the
grimlablin
wow
well that's fun
you can see the strings what those
aren't strings that's funny hair oh look
at this dear the six-pack-a-lope
wordplay
if you look into his eyes you can see
your worst nightmare
why would that be a good idea
[Music]
amazing right
i work for tips
so bad
thanks for shopping with us
[Music]
how many refunds have you given well
maybe you need to start being a little
bit tougher around here i just need to
think positive be friendly and
everything will work out fine yeah
how did he get out of his locked cage
well
[Music]
give him a break he's an employee
sort of he's got rights ladies and
gentlemen stan pines is poised to become
our grand champion anything to say to
your fans out there see you tomorrow
night mabel
no bueno
he's awarding himself stickers that he
didn't even earn make him look into a
mirror fighting a gremlavel and use
water
only as a last resort as water will make
him much much scarier
who writes
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't worry he's gotta leave eventually
[Music]
don't eat the profits no hey monster
take a look at this
smart
[Music]
dude
[Laughter]
don't run from it my guy you'll only
find yourself where you don't want to be
i got a little headache so maybe i
should like not work today and i
actually just met this pack of wolves
and i think they're gonna like raise me
as one of their own
yeah do it go we'll see you on monday
[Music]
i have had it i fought a monster to save
you're acting different you shut your
yaps
oh no
now quit loafing and get to work yes
mabel that's yes
yeah
we've got seven hours to turn this
around let's go people
no
cash flood
oh no
i'm giving none of this to charity
or you could risk everything to double
your money with the bonus worm oh
no so i'm gonna take my winnings pack my
bags and bet them all on the bonus word
oh
no dude
we got toys at nine o'clock but what do
i show them real magic just freaks
people out figure something out
knucklehead ladies and gentle tourists
this shack is oh hey behold the horrible
giant question baby
am i a man am i a baby these are
legitimate questions
have your picture taken with it for a
buck uh ten bucks a hundred bucks
minus the money to replace all the
furniture supplies to fix the shack that
leaves us
dollar
tick-tock oh
did he win
how much did you beat us by i won 300
000
oh no and then
for a chance to double your cash or lose
it all what is a six-letter word you use
to ask for something polite
do i look like an idiot folks
the word is gimme chewies
[Laughter]
this far we're going to give you one
more chance no no no no no no
abracadabra final answer
i'm sorry stan but the word is please
apparently that word can make you money
oh
grunkle stan
i had no idea how hard it was being boss
this place was cuckoo bananas until i
started barking orders at people like
you yeah well it's kind of nice to be
back you know
hmm okay that's enough get off of me and
zeus wendy
[Laughter]
didn't your agreement say something
about stan having to do some kind of
apology dance if he lost
no no it didn't actually yeah i think i
have it in my notes here passion
i'm stan and i was wrong i'm singing the
stan wrong song
jazzier
[Music]
torture the poor guy
bad
that
plays on a lot of real life anxieties
i'd say
it's tough to beat the boss
you shut up
yes sir back to work sir sorry sir
so i guess the lesson today kids is you
got to be a dick
if you are a boss
at
any place
the best way to do it is be a jerk
as often as you can that's real
leadership right there
not that right shish kebab that's my
name i love it
thank you it's better than my regular
name one day we'll explain the mystery
of john's tooth
no never i lost it because i deserved he
wouldn't shut up and get to work
you're like i'm gonna remove teeth one
by one until you're finally on top of
this [ __ ]
yeah yeah man
um that is a funny lesson there's a gray
area i guess you gotta learn some people
work by positive reinforcement
others work by guilt
what what what i got a mirror
were you just looking at me
i don't know what you're talking about
others work uh yeah they need a little
bit of a cracking of the whip
something like more freedom something
like precise punctuality guidelines to
work by
time frames and whatnot but either way i
mean that was a fun episode
that that did play on some real things
that that game show [ __ ] could give you
so much anxiety like there's what is
that one show that elizabeth banks
brought back
it was uh what was that show i mean one
of you guys has to know what i'm talking
about
it wasn't her show no there's a
different one i used to there's a period
of my like during during like 2020 i was
watching like a bunch of game shows for
some reason
and uh
there was one show where like yeah the
lady was down it wasn't the elizabeth
bank show it was a different one where
she was like down to
um she was like up six hundred thousand
dollars and you know she like messed
this next one up she would lose it all
i'm just like
pacing the living room going no it was
elizabeth yeah just like based in the
living room going lady just just buy out
just go
out you're up you're up almost you're
over half a million dollars
anyone could imagine right now this is
crazy there's no need and she ended up
winning and i was like oh thank and that
gives me so much it's like sometimes you
go so far that i'm just like damn why
take the chance
but then afterwards you're like thank
god you went for it geez yeah i know but
uh i'm too superstitious i i don't have
enough faith in myself to be like
that first thousand i'm cashing out
first question i get right of cash i
mean when i play poker if i break even
by the time i find whatever i put in if
i walk out with the same amount of food
and i'm like all right fun game guys
yeah yeah yeah
real real simple things like that i
didn't lose yeah pretty much um so yeah
that stuff is but it's cool how they
like had like a flip here where
the way how mabel had to win her way was
by embodying stan's way and the way stan
could have won as if he embodied mabel's
way yeah it's an interesting flip they
did yeah for sure and i mean i thought
it was fun just to watch everybody
wriggle with their own personal
responsibilities of like oh great now
suze has to figure out how to be the
mascot and now dipper's got to go find
attractions and wendy's just
you know goofing off yeah and i liked
how they brought in
you know dipper who's always
having this fun with like going through
the woods of gravity falls and
finding all kinds of mystical creatures
and
weird voodoo and all that stuff to juju
to go find and then suddenly he
brings something real to the mystery
shack
everyone just writes it off where it
just goes terribly wrong
there's some fun bits with that that
nightmarish thing yeah well i like the i
like the mabel redesign of the mystery
shack this sort of you know still
esoteric but glittery and pink some nice
little goofy music cues for this episode
as well
yeah a lot of the 80s boss nostalgia all
she was missing was a big pile of
cocaine yes
yes
if this is kids if you don't know what
that is that's what they used to put in
soda mm-hmm
right at the very beginning of the
coca-cola yeah those key ingredients
yeah you know when they release the the
pg rated cut that's where all the
cocaine where all the cocaine comes from
yeah you bet i mean you bet grunkle stan
he had like a safe in there he's
probably got tons of cocaine in that
safe he's got no hopes bricks he
deserves a stacked up how do you think
he's able to afford this he's earned it
he's earned all that yeah i like cocaine
he has and he probably overcharges the
citizens of gravity yeah
more than likely yeah it probably deals
it at a terrible rate
um
yeah pretty solid episode yeah that was
that was more like hijinks yeah
absolutely i mean it was nice like it's
one of those i feel like every now and
again you'll get uh that was the best
mabel focused episode yeah i feel like
there's a
one of many types you you might be
liable to come across in an animated
ensemble especially is the like okay
let's yeah let's flip the perspective so
somebody else is kind of the control or
the status one character so yeah even
dipper in this one is a supporting role
more so
and uh yeah it's fun to see everybody
kind of in those lanes out of their
elements and whatnot yeah because
normally mabel is uh supporting
for a dipper adventure and then this is
the first time they gave the ra the
first time i can recall where like she's
really the lead yeah and one that's like
not just such an aloof or stupid you
know like she's she really seems like
for the most part pretty smart here
yeah like
oftentimes they use her character for
yeah like wow yeah wild card absurd
quips and that's a dynamic that works in
moderation and doses and so yeah when
you change the focus to make her the
protagonist i appreciate that they went
okay we have to uh you know uh flesh her
perspective a little further out and
make her you know not just the wild card
all the time she has to anchor
everything and i thought they did a nice
job of that
yeah good [ __ ] man let's grab it false
oh he's a pledge
staying consistently really strong
lately that's right man really enjoying
this good stuff
see what all the hype's about mm-hmm
too bad it got cancelled after one
season that's right no more episodes
after we finished this one season one
season and after that
bye-bye gravity
canceled never had an ending according
to all the comments who corrected me
when i said that it got canceled after
season two
you guys corrected me it got canceled
after season one i really appreciate the
information ladies and gentlemen thank
you for being here uh leave a like leave
your thoughts down below
and
hey let's shout out some patrons
oh my gosh it's josh farrow looky looky
it's choochie randy bain you're
crazy in pain damien mendoza get out on
the floza agent phillip smith and the
oscar goes to acosta oscar acosta jimmy
burns ricardo
zach with the hershey's in his burgers
that's gross
logan barry kogan burton mothers and
dads asmr radio eric khan's 39 and a
half foot pole
cushy cuzy you gotta be so mushy mushy
don't hide her from philip eider don't
stare at the bear in the garage pose
with me rosalie taylor
nickxvideos.com was the first of many
sites i went to gail christian bale
ferguson jaren christian bale wanner
push me off a cliff rodriguez chris
busting all over his belly mr crispy
chicken
thank you guys so much for showing your
support
i love me more than you will ever know
[Music]
you